hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to a box full of joy I don't
know a lot about this game I literally
just opened it up in this screen popped
up here with this text here so night
fell on city's cliffs but nothing
changed the elevator descended she
opened the box the box was empty I'm
guessing that's that box full of joy
that's gonna lead to nothing but
happiness in my future also it was very
highly rated on gamejolt but I shouldn't
have to say that now hello why is there
a dead guy
did somebody murder him with this knife
I've been playing a lot of
point-and-click oh oh damn the blades
shine over the rooftops are you just
waxing philosophical about the fact that
you're about to die oh okay
oh that's me oh is that that's me right
okay I'm playing this hello hi mr. knife
Oh
Oh am I gonna have to quick dots and
[ __ ] here look at look at here hey shiny
thing me em loose too much blood my
brain no works so good once I saw it in
a movie okay let's just count it back
down maybe you should lie down will it I
think it's mine well it's mine now so
I've got the shiny metal bliss oh this
guy is fun at parties I bet alright then
ha I just pulled it out of my bloody
wound don't mind me hey nobody home how
do you know you didn't knock knock with
your knife that would be good
okay so enter there no other cool thing
that I need how about a sample of my own
blood for no reason
ah yes junk please do yes go yes go yes
yes yes there might be some yummy
goodness I know what I think so I think
your wounds need to be tended to do
before you stuff infested food into your
mouth
there might be some oh you're not even
gonna try
all right that's probably for the best
hello bar man hey Stan nice blood don't
get it on my floor Frank yes oh yes I'm
Frank some lady was looking for you
really who I can't see too good anymore
the tall one with the head of gold also
known as blond damn does she know
something she said that she wanted to
return the favor
ha ha ha ha ha otherwise she will dance
a jig oh no anything but that
oh no oh right all right
thanks man cool cool distinguished
gentleman yes indeed distinguished
gentleman one day my glass will have
something to say about what happened
with you out there my glass uh something
really what did it see ask it ok fine uh
need something you're looking great by
the way thanks no thanks I'm fine I
don't think I'm fine things seem to be
going to lose you nonchalantly and very
smooth and quiet I'll go to my room and
have a good nap cuz I live at the bar
beware the lady with a head of code
Frank yeah also notice blood is this
stool drunk the piano has been drinking
not me oh nothing makes sense
I'll go dance spray my blood help is
that like that test where the dancer
spins in a different direction if I look
ok nevermind hello guy who's not wearing
any pants you and I could probably
connect because I believe in that in a
very deep level of me a man
looking bad you in trouble this is a
nice party
Degas pills it will help you if you're
in trouble I'm pretty sure the grammar
is intentional in this game you'll see
right now I've got towels don't tell
Louis but I got pills oops oh well I
suddenly adopted Technicolor Oh righty
then what happens if I go back to the
bars it's like uh is this gonna be fast
oh this is faster I'm dancing a jig
hello where'd all my bar men go where
the drunk distinguished gentlemen go
what's outside
I'm tired of fresh air I don't think the
smell of blood and rotting trash was
very fresh to begin with all right then
we were dreaming of a great deeds laying
in the puddle of drunkenness hi hi back
up a little bit maintain distance when
dancing leave room for Jesus hello it
who the [ __ ] are you Oh what the [ __ ] is
that
okay I bought in Bern that bodies
haunted we were something more than just
lovers great again do you see the shiny
mantle bliss still we were good lovers
great enough bragging about yourself
there's a mystery going on here that I
need solving please pretty please oh
that is disturbingly creepy I gonna have
to dodge wanna talk to you what's funny
nothing nothing just burnt I just wanted
to die like a man but now I'm going to
wear this stupid grin forever Oh what
horrible suffering you endure
I've got the pill oh I found the pill
good let me just shimmy my way over to
the door nobody home again nobody's home
oh oh no it's she I can't possibly be
spotted bra gonna let me shimmy my way
over to you lady hello she I'm gonna
dodge you are you gonna do please Frank
don't leave I was coming towards here I
wasn't leaving or at least take me with
you
ah okay please Frank don't leave feel
like you've said this before but then
again I've lost enough blood that I'm
not sure what you're saying at all also
cranberry
okay do i do I do this right but Dwight
would ya
something tells me I did the wrong thing
oh go there I don't wanna go there
but I want to go there at all oh hey
how's it going ah did I do something bad
okay hello hope I'm doing right
I hope so too because frankly I'm not
sure and that's not a pun on your name
or whatever man I have some more pills
just a drug dealer who them well I'm in
color again shitty shitty Shanga where
am I going now
hello how you doing need me to plug up
that hole with a knife no innuendos and
probably not murder
hello again how's it going burned body
wanna listen to your story it's about a
woman she's currently crying and
bleeding in the other room oh god please
stop oh I want to tell you about my
story friend my story in Luke Assam aku
but got Macau but any Cohen I see your
are the pill in the trash I already got
that thanks nor nobody home nobody home
alright fine I guess
woo boy Jimmy chunga I'm just gonna if I
don't look at you it's like I never did
it okay
this is mildly disturbing kid was
running near the cliff after that he was
lying below I'm assuming this a middle
step that you're not filling me in on
that maybe I should know okay back up a
little bit there I don't need to get
that closer you might stab me Shane do
something bad what is that me how is
that a thing
where's the box full of joy come on that
ain't natural
I can't even shimmy no more where's my
knife I don't even have a knife okay all
right I'm just a walking cross I guess I
found the pill good what does the pill
gonna do me hello bar man don't mind me
just perfectly normal state figure
walking by it's gonna help you I was too
scared to say anything also I was a
stick a bloody stick well the show has
already started come on in oh boy me as
a stick person I love shows hope there's
dancing oh boy everybody's dead with
sticks hello are you my wife
oh you're she sorry I mistook you for
someone else
Oh
we meet I don't know
I cannot squeeze out a single sound
because I'm a stick I mean I don't know
my throat is dry could you get me a
drink
probably but I can't hold it cuz I'm a
stick so I mean I want to help you but
also I have a knife also everybody's
dead did you do that I think it might
have been me cuz I'm a stick me just
walk through we have our man there's a
pretty girl with a head of gold huh
what's happened here
take this man don't a house oh it's
balancing on my stick head thank you
I've got a drink oh thank you you know
it's getting late could you maybe walk
me home stick man cigar ha ha I live
right around the club do you know oh do
you live in that door that I know so
much about all right well don't walk do
slowly it's gonna be great oh hi ah that
was a little weird I'm just gonna ignore
that probably because I'm a stick I
might not have even seen that coming Wow
all right then I'll just okay hello she
this not weird well here's where I live
hot stickman would you like to descend
Oh
or I and you are no innuendo innuendo
and you endo ha okay okay doesn't when I
had mind
hi kid this is the weirdest game I've
ever played
hey Dad can I go for a walk I don't know
can you huh I'm dad have you finished
the homework
yeah - watch your language young man
whatever I don't even want go out why
because you can't also I think your face
is stapled and ceiling also it's
exploded but I won't judge my wife how
you doing
nice staplers hey sweetheart we ran out
of garbage I was going to go out anyway
I love you
well this is an outside oh okay alrighty
then
the living room could use some
decoration whose blood is this smells
like mine what are what happened here I
probably died maybe who knows little
garbage it's exactly what I wanted
I've got garbage I better take it in
here hello distinguished gentlemen how
are you doing how much more do I need to
drink to remember her I don't know the
bartender said that she was hurt
yesterday yesterday there has been only
you maybe she's here right now in a
different world with pills
Paperman how's that hey Stan what's up
my man
just time to know how you're doing
things are going well tomorrow will be a
new show anyway how's your sex life hey
how's your sex life mark I better I
better go I gotta attend to my sex life
doc yeah no show tonight well poopie
I'll just take my bag garbage and just
go on my way oh my lovely wife are you
and okay oh boy time for seizures oh
goody she redecorated my wife where's my
son hmm garbage where's the boy he's
right here look what
okay
I know surreal but this is just bizarre
hi after I died we ran around the block
now it's open oh hi martyr me this ISM
is that I'm going to murder me yours at
the martyr me I am in a great danger
okay Oh
bogey huh hey Donna yeah ah good oh no
pill pill god damn it
Oh I took a pill I do some goodie I'll
get it okay whatever I was gonna do this
game is fine what the hell's happening
hello is that also me oh I look good
okay as much dude oh hey pure a pure
great a nightmare okay
glad to know the chemistry is floating
in the background hello don't be afraid
we are talking to the Beast it's Barry
cutted throat he betrayed each family Oh
completely logical it was not fighting
when its family was hunted down it
wanted to escape so I took off his skin
thanks you saved me some trouble so guy
how you doing how's it going you have to
believe me I do not I do not
oh I thought I was gonna have a choice
here do I not have a choice ha
all right fine then I guess I got
nothing to do kill it
Oh Oh kill it anyway the Beast will not
survive the Beast suffers Oh ease is
suffering okay let me do one of these
first I don't want to do that you're not
a guy at all yeah I'm gonna set it free
good thing I had that last pill to
really show me what for then appease the
soil with you room yeah no no I refuse
i'ma get you here I know I need to stop
Devin oh my head I hate it when I
stabbed myself in the gut my head falls
off
oh my okay bye
this is oh I'm still playing okay I
thought it was gonna be the end that's a
lot of heads it was at a loss skulls
I mean save difference I guess this is
the end of the game magis step 104 ever
okay okay good good
Hey
oh I've been wandering around for a
while and I literally think this might
be the end of the game I mean the game
is weird enough that it might just end
on this note here so that's all for now
thank you everybody so much for watching
and literally don't even know what to
say about this it's so weird
everything was so weird about it I was
trying to piece together whatever
message we're trying to say and it make
any sense so if you could make any sense
of this please educate us in the
comments down below tell us what is
going on here what is happening I don't
know so either way thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video